It's the same guys that you don't have for years. I mean,
obviously I'm such a big gun guy, right?
So the same guys that for years told me, why do you need an AR 15?
There's no background check. It's ridiculous. You know, Don, what AR 15,
should I buy, um, John? Oh my God, there's a waiting period. What's going on?
I want a gun there's stuff going on in my neighborhood. I mean,
I go for 10 years, you told me that these things didn't exist.
Cause you had no idea, but that was the talking point. You know,
I think they're waking up to how ridiculous it's become.
Do you miss the good liberals? Because we talked about this last time,
but you're a new Yorker. You grew up mostly around liberals. Uh,
I know you have a lot of friends that are still liberals. Like,
do you miss that, that New York liberal,
that was not sort of the bananas left?
I do. And it's sort of interesting. I mean,
some of them are still that way and honestly, some of them are just like,
I can't believe what's going on. I'm like,
you know the same guys that you don't have for years. I mean,
obviously I'm such a big gun guy, right?
So the same guys that for years told me, why do you need an AR 15?
There's no background check. It's ridiculous. You know, Don, what AR 15,
should I buy John? Oh my God, there's a waiting period. What's going on?
I want a gun there's stuff going on in my neighborhood. I mean,
I go for 10 years, you told me that these things didn't exist.
Cause you had no idea, but that was the talking point. You know,
I think they're waking up to how ridiculous it's become. So, you know,
it's been a little bit cathartic for me because you know, those radicals that,
you know, just, you literally, you know,
I used to be able to put myself in their shoes, argue their point.
It's not like I stick to a a hundred percent conservative dogma.
You know that in the conversations we've had way before we even got into
politics. I'm pretty open about that. And yet, you know,
I used to be able to argue those points.
I can't argue the mainstream Democrat platform anymore with a straight face and
be like, this is, this is somehow good for America. Most of them can't and,
and that's the problem. They see it. So there's plenty of those Democrats.
I know a bunch that are just like, yeah, you know,
we don't love every aspect of what you're doing, but like w we believe in gummy,
we believe in freedom. We believe in freedom of speech. We believe in,
and you're listing these things that, you know,
I said it in my convention speech, like, you know,
freedom of speech and thought that used to be a liberal value, you know,
try wearing, you know, tolerance used to be a liberal value. I mean,
they still run around. They're the party of tolerance. I'm saying,
try wearing a Maga hat in Portland, you know,
try wearing a Maga hat and one of these major cities. Now,
if you wore a Biden hat and I haven't seen any of them,
but if someone made one and water's gotta be one somewhere where it,
in the most, you know, I don't want to call it Maga country.
That's a Jessie Smollett special. But like, uh, you know, in,
in the most conservative, no one's gonna, they won't even say anything to you.
They won't, they won't spit at you. They won't throw you,
they won't beat you over the head with a brick.
Like you're seeing in these videos, you know, they won't lose your store,
cancel your business,
or you'll get petitions going to ruin your life on Facebook. They won't do that,
but try doing it the other way. So, you know, the party of tolerance,
isn't so tolerant. And I think a lot of reasonable Democrats, you know, uh,
get that. I also think a lot of, sort of that, that history,
that blue collar working class union in the headache tradition of voting that
way, I think they get it too. They're saying, what is, you know,
I used to hear it at 16. Well, you know, no one,
if my grandfather knew that I was voting for a Republican,
he'd be rolling over in his grave. I go, well,
what would he say about today's Democrat platform? Not that one. And he goes,
huh. You know, you're, you're right. Done. Like, Oh my God, I go,
how many genders are there? 96 or two, what would he say? You know, John F.
Kennedy, you know, this pillar of the Democrat party, he'd be all right today,
Dave, he'd be canceled. Right. He'd be tuned and canceled. And it would be over.
I mean, uh, it's just not your grandfather's Democrat party anymore.
And I think that has ostracized, you know,
so many former Democrats where they're starting to become, you know,
either somewhat conservative, uh, moderates or, or really, you know,
sort of libertarian in many of their views, which are so many of my views too.
Yeah. I, I hear you, man. And we've had many discussions about it. Let's,
let's jump to a private discussion we had about it. Cause I think it'll,
it'll get to something really interesting here, which is, uh, my,
my audience has heard it, but one night, uh, you,
you and Kimberly invited David and I to dinner at Mar-a-Lago.
We had a really nice dinner. We argued about politics for two, three hours. Uh,
I had a couple drinks. You do not drink. So I'm not sure who won the arguments,
but we did about three hours there. And then at the end, you,
your dad was there. And by the way,
this was right at the beginning of impeachment. And everybody said,
the walls were closing in. He's freaking out the guy sitting there,
he has no tie on.
He was with Giuliani and people and he's laughing and having fun. Anyway,
at the end of dinner, you said, Hey, would you like to meet my dad?
And I was like, uh, yeah, I'd like to meet the president. Let's let's do it.
And you introduce us. And then he turns to David and he says, well, who are you?
And David says, well, I'm his husband and your dad immediately. Like,
there was no pause. He clapped his hands together. He slapped him on the table.
He said, that's great. That's just great.
I want to stand up and shake your hands. He shakes our hands. He says,
the only thing wrong with you guys is you're too handsome. Melania,
can you believe it? These handsome guys are married.
And it was just so obvious to me that in this completely unscripted,
unplanned moment where you just brought us up to him, that he,
he actually said, I don't know if he wants me to say it,
but I've said it before. He said, I want you guys to know something.
I don't give a. And I don't think anyone's given a in,
in 20 years talking about, about gay marriage or whatever. Um,
how do you get over the labels when it comes to something like that?
Just the base stuff your dad is,
or your family is homophobic or they're racist because no matter how many
times I tell that story, people say I'm a sell out somehow or so. You know,
some version of some of that stuff.
That, well, the reality is this,
Donald Trump is the first person to run for president of the United States.
That when he ran, he was for gay marriage. I mean,
Obama was against it because he was told he had to be against it.
And maybe he wasn't in his actual convictions, but as part of his platform,
he was against it because that's what they had to do. Right.
That's you listen to the talking points and you must to them. So, you know,
again, Donald, Trump's been way ahead of that curve.
I think we have we've we're from New York. I mean,
it's like a pretty big percentage of the people around us at any given time are
probably, we just don't care what you do in your own. You know, who gives a?
No one, no one's going to care. It's one of those issues. You're right. I mean,
we're already there, frankly,
but it's one of yours it'll be even even different. Right. Even more so, I mean,
even some of the older school people that, you know, may be a little bit more,
you know, just to kinda read the, sort of the older religious dogma on it.
Like no one cares. Even the people that say they care, no, they don't care.
They sort of, they feel obligated to do it.
Donald Trump just had the guts to be like, Hey, I don't care.
I'm running for the Republican nomination.
And this is not an issue for me whatsoever. Go ahead. Have at it.
I always joke that the best wedding I ever went to was a gay wedding because it
was on a Tuesday. They were like, well, we don't want to screw up your weekend.
We're just gonna have fun on a Tuesday. I think that's perfect.
This is the greatest wedding ever. I don't have to lose my whole weekend.
That's awesome. I love you guys. Um, and so, you know, he has a kid, but again,
you see it every day. Donald Trump has been so bad.
I think you guys didn't have a problem with Obama,
literally running against gay marriage in 2008,
but Donald Trump runs as a, as a conservative,
you literally going against the, you know, the more traditional dog. Again,
I don't think it's a party platform issue at this point. I don't it,
like I said, I don't think anyone cares. So they probably haven't for a while,
but he literally said, I don't care. Well, you know, guess what? You know,
you're a Republican,
you're trying to get the evangelical vote and you still say, Hey,
I don't care about that. Let people live and let live. I mean,
the Republican party is the true party of tolerance.
Now that doesn't mean I've been open about this too.
And it doesn't mean I don't draw the line. Some places again,
I don't care how you even identify, where I start to care is when you know,
you're six, two, two 85 and Jack,
and you decide you want to be a woman and compete against, you know,
my daughter is sports. You know, I,
I don't identify how you want, but you start taking her scholarship.
I have a problem.
I wonder where the people who fought for title nine are how come they won't say
anything. But it's interesting when I've come out on some of those things.
And again, I don't give a crap if you're trans or not,
that makes no difference to me. It's when you sort of let's,
let's have the best, let's take a female athlete. Who's top of her game.
Who's worked her whole life. I'm a journeyman male athlete.
That's not working out so well, congratulations. I'm going to flip it.
Now I'm a state champion. I'm getting your scholarship.
I have a problem with that. And I've said it I've been very vocal about it.
I've even put it out on Twitter.
And it's interesting because if I put out anything on Twitter, you know,
before someone could have even read, you know, read my tweet,
they're up there with the hate mail and the hate commentary.
But when I do that one, it's sort of interesting. I get this note like,
ah, man, God did it, but I hate him, but I'm with Don Jr. On this one.
And for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of
nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.